Варіант створення уряду в Німеччині трьома політичними силами
консерваторами, лібералами та зеленими - зазнав поразки.
Місяць після виборів не лише німці запитують: а що далі?
Багато оглядачів прогнозують нові вибори.
Втім, не все так просто.
Спочатку федеральний президент має
запропонувати когось на посаду канцлера.
Це може бути Анґела Меркель
як представниця найсильнішої фракції Бундестагу.
Якщо більшість депутатів підтримає її, вона очолить уряд.
Якщо ні - парламент матиме два тижні
на визначення спільної кандидатури.
Якщо ж канцлера оберуть відносною більшістю
президент зможе затвердити його на цій посаді
фактично привівши до влади уряд меншості
У цьому випадку новому канцлеру доведеться постійно шукати союзників
для кожного рішення, яке потрібно ухвалити.
Таку модель в Німеччині на федеральному рівні
іще жодного разу не випробовували.
Та й експерти ставлять цю можливість під сумнів.
Адже, зважаючи на непрості політичні часи
Анґелі Меркель було би вкрай незручно
щоразу шукати підтримки в тієї чи іншої опозиційної партії.
Іще одна опція - президент ФРН розпускає парламент
і призначає нові вибори.
Вони відбуваються впродовж наступних
двох місяців після такого оголошення.
Крім того, теоретично ХДС міг би спробувати домовитися
про відновлення широкої коаліці
з Соціал-демократичною партією Німеччини
яка отримала другий результат на виборах до Бундестагу
Втім, керівництво СДПН одразу ж після виборів відкинуло
нову широку коаліцію з Меркель і
заявило заявило про перехід в опозицію.
Ба більше - минулими вихідними лідер політсили Мартін Шульц
заявив, що його партія у будь-який момент готова до нових перегонів.